[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here
welcome to my second episode of chess
gambit buster
in today's lecture we are going to look
at
very famous yet very dangerous
stafford gambit and you will be
delighted to watch this video until the
end
as not only you are going to equip
with a very easy to learn system against
it
but as you will see that white get a
quick advantageous position just within
the opening stage well the critical
stafford position
can be arise with a different motor so
for example
after e4 e5 and knight to f3
black can choose either the move knight
to f6
or bishop to c5 by far
the most popular choice is in knight to
f6
and after that actually white can choose
two different path to reach the desired
stafford position
first let's look the most obvious one
where white capture on e5
and rather than trying to get his pawn
back black played the moon knight to c6
gambiting his center pawn
here white ken declined the gambit and
roll back
but i am going to recommend the except
variation that is
knight capture c6 pawn capture c6
and although here white has multiple
options
you play this straightforward move
knight to c3
defending e4 pawn where after
black plays bishop to c5 and guess what
yup we reached to one of the most
poisonous position of this variation
the second more order i like the most
as if you have watched my dirty chest
tricks
43 and 44 episode then
i have recommended knight to c3 move
here
and if black really wants to enter into
the staffer territory
then he has to play bishop to c5
after that by force we can reach to
the same territory knight captures e5
knight to c6 knight capture c6
and after pawn capture c6 guess what
different path but leads to
same desired destination
now before we dive into theory just to
make you comfortable
i have created two phase plan for you
and let me reveal it right now
so face number one is very easy
white plays very important move h3
and followed up with d3
if there is no attack on f2
so that is face number one
okay now comes phase two
and this is very important guys
because it all depends where your
opponent
wants to castle so in the case
where black tried to castle on the king
side
we are going to follow it up with bishop
to e2
and castle on the same side
and if your opponent tried to castle on
the queen side
then we followed up with moves such as
queen to e2 and bishop to e3
trying to castle on the same side
so if you can remember these two phases
no matter whatever mu order black can
throw up on you
not only you can easily defuse it but
you get a very easy to play and
a comfortable position
so keeping these things in mind let's
see
how we can achieve it against
different black mu order
here we go phase number one very
important move
h3 and as you can see i have highlighted
by the arrows
black has mainly four good tries
well amongst them h5 and queen to d4
are the most popular one where the other
twos
are related to quick castle on the
either side
let's see each by turn and find out
how effectively our phase theory
work against them
the first move i want to consider is h5
which is in fact as per the database the
most frequent choice
however against our setup
probably it is the weakest one
and if you remember of a phase one then
you can easily spot white's next reply
yup d3
not only creating a super pawn chain
but meanwhile setting up
some nasty ideas
can you believe the only good move in
this position is
bishop to e6 as rest of the black moves
leads to opening disaster
yup you heard it right in my online
blitz
i have seen this move frequently namely
queen to d4 which i think
played by a player who does not know the
theory well
and clearly cannot distinguish the small
difference
white has made congratulations to black
as he fall into our first tricky
territory
and white response is very obvious
bishop to e3 attacking the queen
clearly queen has the only place to go
b4
because let's say if it goes to
somewhere else
then we have this tactical sequence
which nabbing the piece
e5 queen captures e5 and d4
winning the piece on the spot
so that's why queen to b4 is forced here
and after that yet another attacking
move
a3 again black has to be very careful
as he simply cannot take on b2
due to the familiar tactic
yup knight to a4 double attack
and after the only move queen to e5 and
knight capture c5
white emerge with a clear piece
advantage
so clearly after a3
black has to play queen to b6
but now black queen is in serious danger
of trapping down there
and on top of everything white has this
initiative
d4 attacking the bishop bishop to e7
and finally i recommend this simple move
bishop to c4
and if you carefully look at this
position not only
white come up with a clear pawn
advantage
but black all threats are gone
and surprisingly if you run this
position
in any chess engine it gives you plus
three yep plus three that is close to
winning
advantage to the white camp
in case if you are wondering why not
queen to b2
here well the answer is very simple
knight to a4 and the black sweetie is a
corner
well apart from it white has a very
simple idea
such as e5 castle and plain knight to a4
which may be in some line trapping down
the black queen all in all
i think with the accurate play white can
finish up the game
from this position very quickly
okay let's look at the second disaster
move
namely castle on the king side
and once you play h5 this move doesn't
make any sense
however you should exactly know
what is the reason as if you remember
my phase 2 now if black castle on the
king side
our plan is yup bishop to e2
and trying to castle on the same side
well fortunately here white is hitting
the second pawn
and if black doesn't defend it then we
are happy to lop it off
so black response is force but after
that
there is no second invitation required
bam
and sooner black king will be
ripped apart
if black continue here with h4 then
after bishop to g5
black loses his second pawn so that's
not good
and any obvious moves let's say rook to
e8
we can simply rip apart the king's side
with g captures h5 knight captures h5
bishop captures h5 and after pawn
captures h5 and rook to g1
black can simply pack his back and go
home
the third move i want to consider is
queen to d6
and obviously enough black wants to
castle on the queen side
so if you now remember my phase 2
white's obvious plan is yup
queen to e2
[Music]
and amazingly enough this instantly
create the thread
that is e5 so black has to deal with it
and accordingly after queen to e7
i think black has wasted a huge time
and we can follow it up with bishop to
e3
and after this no matter however black
plays
white get a completely upper hand
if bishop to b4 then bishop to d2 is a
very strong reply
and apart from it let's say if
black continue with his plan namely
bishop to e6
trying to remain flexible on either side
castle
well we can do the same by developing
our light square bishop
with first f4
threatening f5 so black has to stop it
with g6
and the typical root of our light square
bishop
g3 bishop to g2 and
we are more than happy to castle on the
same side
so if castle long then we can castle
immediately
with a healthy pawn advantage and
if black castle short then we can play
bishop to g2
and after castle once again the same
story
extra pawn with the space on the king
side
white is clearly better
last but not least what about bishop to
e6
same story guys queen to e2
and this time black can take benefit as
he has not committed queen to d6
so he can continue with queen to e7
but our plan will not change bishop to
e3
black castles and after we castles
again as you can see by the arrows the
simple
but effective plan of campaign by white
which is so good against all of this
slow setups by the black camp
okay let's check out the second black
big alternative namely castle on the
king side
and after that first let us finish
our first phase yup d3
[Music]
and as black has castle on the king side
our obvious face to plan is we wants to
play bishop to e2
and castle on the king's side
now as i have explained earlier black
cannot play queen to d4
because of bishop to e3 and
it doesn't matter if we continue with
either rook 2 e8 or queen to d6
let's say rook 2 e8 is engine's top
choice
we are going to respond obviously with
bishop to e2
and now black plays tricky move queen to
d6
and one thing you should always watch
out before castling that
if you prematurely castle then after
bishop to h3
black is right back in the game as
he has some threads looming from the g3
square
so please don't fall for this
my golden rule is that whenever i wants
to castle on the king's side
and if black had played the move queen
to d6
i always respond with this key move and
you should remember this
queen to d2 so at first sight it looks
very weird because you are blocking your
own bishop
but as you can see white has an obvious
idea he
wants to first neutralize this diagonal
so that he can safely castle
a sample line can goes like this bishop
to e6
black is finishing its development we
challenge the queen
with queen to f4 and no way black wants
to exchange the queen
as he is going to be a clear pawn down
so queen to d7 but after that
since our king is now completely safe
we can safely castle and in fact
this position is dangerous for the black
as in one of my blitz game my opponent
casually
continued with obvious looking moon
rook a to d8 centralizing their rooks
but unfortunately after white's next
reply
queen to g3 suddenly
white has some threat looming including
bishop to g5
bishop to h6 and do not forget
the obvious plan namely king to h1
and then rolling the f pawn
well all together i think this is really
fun to play as a white
especially with a whole pawn advantage
the third move i want to consider is
queen to d6
where black aims to castle quickly on
the queen side
and obviously enough we are going to
respond with our familiar
d3 and when black plays
bishop to v6 once again this queen to e2
move
creating headache for the black camp
white has already a threat of e5 and
surprisingly
in the leeches there are 12 games played
where in all of these games black
castles on the queen side
and white played e5 and managed to get
a completely winning position
but let's say even though your opponent
doesn't fall for it
either he has to waste the move such as
queen to e7
where after bishop to e3 white is
completely
dominating and the other critical
response
bishop to d4 can be met
with knight to d1 that's the engine's
original choice
but we will remain very consistent with
our face
theory and my suggestion here is
yup bishop to d2 defending
the knight if queen to b4
then knight to d1 is a very strong reply
and black can choose which side he wants
to castle
where we are going to follow him up so
if he cancel on the queen side then we
can do the same
and after king to be it as there is no
h5 here
you can even improve with our setup
starting with g4
and once white get the space with bishop
g2 and f4
i think black is really struggling not
only with the pawn down
but the space in the center
last but the most critical move in this
position is
queen to d4 which clearly stopping our
d3 idea
as black is attacking too soft spot
and although queen to f3 is engine's top
choice
we are going to be very consistent with
our face structure
and accordingly i am going to recommend
queen to e2 okay
black has few choices number one
if we continue with bishop to e6
planning to castle on the queen side
not a big deal for us because we can
complete our
phase one d3 and
after long castle bishop to e3
defuse all blacks attack
the only thing you have to know that
after queen to b4
do not take on c5 as black is
threatening queen captures b2
so first just castle
and now as we seen in earlier part
our space gain on the king side with
extra pawn
gives white a great advantage
okay what about the second move castle
on the king side
no issues we are going to continue with
d3
completing our first phase and
after rook to e8 bishop to e3
is the obvious choice and i guess this
is the only scenario
where after queen to b4 white is forced
to castle on the queen side
but if you carefully look at this
position
it is white whose attack comes very
quickly on the black king
where black attack is bit slow
on our queen side
well that is the reason why chess engine
suggests that
black should go for the sequence bishop
captures e3
queen captures e3 and now knight to d5
taking the advantage of the pin and
double attacking on c3 which
by force reached to the end game
after queen to d2 knight capture c3
queen capture c3 queen capture c3 and
pawn capture c3 well the end result is
pretty clear
both the side has a set of double pawn
but
with the extra pawn white is clearly
at the driving seat
last but probably the most testing reply
against our setup is bishop to b4
which clearly stop our d3 plan
and i think this is the only variation
where
you need to know how you are going to
respond aggressively
and my recommendation is you guessed it
yup if i
if knight to d7 then e6 is a very strong
reply
so accordingly the best response here is
knight to d5 attacking the c3 knight
three times but after white's next
tricky reply
knight to d1
[Laughter]
not so surprisingly once again black is
finding
the difficulty clearly white is a threat
of c3 and nabbing a piece
so he has to avoid it and after the
following obvious continuation
bishop to e7 c3
queen to a4 and now d4
look at that wonderful pawn chain
white is clearly dominating in the
center
and some of you may ask but what about
bishop to e6
as black is clearly ahead in terms of
peace development
and yes indeed it's true but
after knight to e3 believe it or not
black cannot even castle
why what happens if we cancel on
either side well here is the answer
what has this wonderful resource queen
to c2
and believe me by force
black has to exchange the queen
well what happens if black tried to
decline it
with queen 25
guess what big time blunder
as after knight to c4 by force
black is losing the queen as she has
only two vacant squares available and
it doesn't matter wherever she goes
after knight to d6 a discover attack
and black queen does not belong
to this world
so that means here black is obliged to
exchange the queen
and after knight capture c2
obviously white is entering into the end
game
where he is a clear pawn up and black
has some double pawn
on the queen side and it is just
matter of time where white will take out
his pieces
this endings are clearly favoring the
white camp
that's it guys i hope with this mini
informative video
now you are confident enough to meet the
stafford gambit
just remember my two phase theory
and whatever surprise black can throw
on the board you can not only easily
dealt with it but white get
a quick advantages position just within
the opening stage thank you for watching
this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you
in my next episode very soon bye
and take care